les costumes le pas chorégraphié
d'outiller les gardes devant le
parlement grec font toujours le bonheur
des vacanciers alors que le pays
s'apprête à connaître une année
touristique record près de 14 % de
touristes de plus que l'an dernier
et d'après l'union européenne les grecs
ont aujourd'hui une autre bonne raison
de célébrer car le pays est
officiellement libéré de la tutelle
financière européenne un moment qui est
très important je tiens même historique
pour nous tous a et d'abord pour le
peuple grec
une page qui se tourne sur huit années
douloureuses de crise économique et de
rigueur budgétaire marqué par des
manifestations d'une rare violence
depuis 2010 la grèce a connu pas moins
de trois plans de soutien financier
européen des prêts totalisant plus de
430 milliards de dollars une aide
assortie d'un régime minceur imposé par
les créanciers de bruxelles austérité
budgétaire réformes drastiques poussant
au chômage au delà des 27 pour cent les
grecs ont payé cher la remise sur les
rails de leur économie
alors aujourd'hui ils n'ont pas le coeur
à la faillite est illettrée sauvetage de
l'économie de réagir pour nous dit cette
dame nos salaires ne vont pas augmenter
et les services de santé sont toujours
aussi horrible
la réduction drastique des dépenses
publiques s'est souvent fait sur le dos
des plus vulnérables comme les retraités
giorgos vague et la kos a vu son revenu
disponible diminué de moitié
et alors qu'il doit aujourd'hui tenter
de survivre avec 300 dollars par mois
il est confronté chaque jour à des choix
très difficiles réussi cette fois à
surveiller des raisins il devrait
demander crédit pour acheter d oran ce
n'est pas que de s'adonner à un
arrachement cette ère d'abondance
on ne peut pas se permettre d'acheter
quoi que ce soit le style et on attend
avec impatience chaque mois l'argent
notre retraite juste pour pouvoir payer
nos des légers d'actionnaires de ce mode
arène et l'austérité est loin d'être
terminée si le chômage baisse et si
l'économie montre de timides signes de
reprise avec une croissance d'un peu
plus de 1%
la dette publique représente toujours
180 % du pib
les grecs le savent ils sont loin
d'avoir fini payer ici jean françois
bélanger a du canada paris